von hamburg bis mainz mehrere städte
setzen über ostern auf nächtliche
ausgangssperren wie sinnvoll ist das
ringen um den richtigen partner die
grünen in baden württemberg wollen
weiter mit der cdu reden trotz
widerständen und peinliche niederlage in
der wm qualifikation deutschland
verliert gegen nord mazedonien
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
gründonnerstag norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport keine frohe
botschaft zu ostern von der
weltgesundheitsorganisation die
infektions lage in europa sei
besorgniserregend wie seit monaten nicht
mehr
und das im tempo inakzeptabel langsam
die bundesregierung bemüht sich
gegenzusteuern ab dienstag sollen in
ganz deutschland hausärzte impfen
die 35.000 beteiligten hausarztpraxen
bekommen in der woche nach ostern
940.000 dosen zunächst fast
ausschließlich von biontech weise ende
april so die hoffnung könnte den praxen
wöchentlich drei millionen impfdosen zur
verfügung gestellt werden dass bohnsack
in der praxis von dr böttcher wartet man
geradezu auf den impfstoff der
brandenburger landtags kennt die meisten
seiner patienten seit jahren und weiß
wer das vakzin am nötigsten braucht es
wird auch endlich zeit dass die
kompetenz wieder zurückkommen zu den
hausärzten damit die hausärzte ihre
eigenen patienten ihr klientel was sie
ja kennen wenn ich sage es ist 50 jahre
kennen die großeltern die enkel und weiß
doch wer wo dran ist
nach ostern sollen die hausärzte der
impfkampagne einen neuen schub geben ist
in der ersten woche noch relativ wenig
impfstoff da sollen ende april bereits
drei millionen dosen wöchentlich
verimpft werden indem wir mit dem impfen
in den arztpraxen beginnen etablieren
wir strukturen die uns perspektivisch
helfen schneller und mehr zu impfen und
mit perspektive meine ich jetzt nicht in
vielen monaten sondern schon in wenigen
wochen werden wir die zahlen auch dort
deutlich steigern können auch apotheken
und großhandel die für kühlketten und
logistik verantwortlich sind zeigen sich
gewappnet wir werden gerade zu anfang
wenn die mengen noch knapp sind
sicherstellen müssen dass der impfstoff
er auf die apotheken in den
bundesländern verteilt wird
tatsächlich wecken politik und
ärzteschaft mit ihren ankündigungen so
etwas wie hoffnung
das ist ja die entscheidende botschaft
denn damit wird es dann gelingen
tatsächlich auch tritt zu fassen und
kontrolle über diese pandemie zu
bekommen und sie damit hoffentlich dann
auch zu beginn boden ist präsident
steinmeier ließ sich derweil mit
astrazeneca impfen
der 65 jährige forderte dabei die bürger
auf impf angebote wahrzunehmen
das impfen ist vor allem ein wettlauf
gegen die ansteckende hre und
gefährlichere britische mutter die macht
nach angaben des robert-koch-instituts
mittlerweile fast 90 prozent aller
corona infektionen aus das zeigt sich in
den zahlen das rk ii meldet 24.300 neue
infektionen innerhalb von 24 stunden das
sind 1600 43 mehr als vor einer woche
es gab 201 weitere todesfälle
die sieben tage inzidenz steigt auf
134,2 was tun gegen die immer höher
steigende dritte welle
einige setzen auf nächtliche
ausgangssperren allerdings gehen die
bundesländer damit sehr unterschiedlich
um drei beispiele in bayern gelten
ausgangssperren mittlerweile in drei
vierteln des landes in nordrhein
westfalen das hat in etwa vergleichbare
corona zahlen nur in einem einzigen
kreis und der bericht von anselm stern
beginnt in hamburg wo die bürger ab
morgen nachts nicht mehr raus dürfen
raus in den frühling gegen die pandemie
müdigkeit die sehnsucht nach echter
normalität
doch das rausgehen wird in immer mehr
städten und kreisen eingeschränkt
nächtliche ausgangssperren zum beispiel
hier in hamburg ab morgen zwischen 21
und 5 uhr auf einer station
und ich finde dass die spender zu spät
kommt also ich denke ganz ehrlich das
ist schwachsinnig die meinungen sehr
unterschiedlich große studien zum nutzen
von corona ausgangssperren in
deutschland gibt es nicht messen aber
kann man wie viel wir unterwegs sind
eine erkenntnis der humboldt-uni etwa
zwölf prozent der mobilität findet
zwischen 20 und 5 uhr statt mobilität
heißt in der regel auch kontakte es geht
darum kontakte zu reduzieren indem
volumen aber auch in der struktur das
heißt man kann jetzt nicht verschiedene
modelle und datenanalysen anschauen und
es spielt eben immer noch eine rolle
dass ihr im privaten bereich noch viele
kontakte haben um kontakte neue
ansteckungen generell zu reduzieren
seien ausgangssperren ein
notfallinstrument so der experte
ein instrument mit schwächen etwa wenn
die für den abend geplanten kontakte
einfach vorverlegt werden
fest steht die mobilität ist aktuell
viel höher als in ersten shut down
anonyme mobilfunkdaten zeigen 22,5
millionen bewegungen pro tag im märz
2020 jetzt 70,8 millionen halle sind ja
total müde und können nicht mehr
und da ist das einfach ganz natürlich
dass man sich so ganz von alleine wieder
in diesem normalzustand zurück bewegt
und deshalb sind wir auch diese riesen
unterschiede in der mobilität
unterschiedlich bleiben auch die
positionen bei den chor ohne regeln in
deutschland ja wir erleben das zweite
ostern im schatten von corona wieder mit
dem dringenden appell an alle auf große
familien zusammenkünfte und nicht
notwendige reisen zu verzichten
die mehrheit folgt dem offenbar andere
geben der sehnsucht nach tapetenwechsel
und urlaub nach hinten klingen
check-in unter anderem für mallorca die
schlangen sind lang am frankfurter
flughafen und die stimmung bei den
urlaubern ist gemischt
ich habe selbst ein bisschen schlechtes
gewissen irgendwo an sich quatsch
besuche meine eltern bin auf einer finca
die sind über 80 die möchte ich gerne
mal im leben noch mal sehen wir haben
einen eigenen betrieb und arbeiten sehr
viel im moment und von daher sind wir
auch wirklich jetzt mal reif für den
urlaub und brauchen auch einfach mal
diese auszeit mehr verreisen fehlen wir
sind gern unterwegs und wir lassen uns
deswegen an schränken wir machen pz ist
wenn wir hinfliegen
wir machen einsätzen zurückkommen hast
du da groß passieren
insgesamt rechnet der frankfurter
flughafen über die osterfeiertage mit
rund 50.000 reisenden pro tag da
mallorca nicht mehr als risikogebiet
gilt bieten lufthansa und condor mehr
flüge auf die baleareninsel an als
geplant
ganz grundsätzlich sind wir aber in
diesen osterferien in diesem jahr mit
etwa zehn prozent des fluges unterwegs
das heißt verhältnismäßig im vergleich
zu den vorjahren mit wesentlich weniger
kapazität auch am berliner flughafen
wollen viele richtung süden
die bahn erwartet keine besonders vollen
züge über die feiertage
jetzt ist er leer das sind ja sonst ist
zu ostern menge los ja aber das ist kein
thema wie sich allein zu hause und ist
dann recht wichtig dass da besuche ich
meine eltern
die meisten werden aber wohl in diesem
jahr zu hause bleiben und das beste
daraus machen regeln über ostern was wo
erlaubt es dazu gleich nach uns ein zdf
spezial bei unseren nachbarn liegen die
infektionszahlen noch höher
österreich hat seit beginn der pandemie
schon dreimal die notbremse ziehen
müssen jeweils mit deutlich
drastischeren maßnahmen als deutschland
und jetzt zum vierten mal wenn auch nur
im osten des landes betroffen sind
niederösterreich wien und das burgenland
dort liegt die inzidenz bei rund 300 für
mindestens zehn tage wird das
öffentliche leben erheblich
eingeschränkt wolf christian ulrich lork
josef winkler frisiert die prominenz bis
hin zum bundeskanzler heute muss er
seinen salon nun zum
vierten mal schließen wieder ein
shutdown obwohl man in österreich
ohnehin nur nach corona test zum friseur
darf wir haben alle die masken auf es
wird immer alles desinfiziert wir kommen
alle mit einem aktuellen test ja
natürlich hätte mir das so weiterführen
können
aber hast so unbeliebter ist ich glaube
dass das die richtige entscheidung ist
in wien liegen inzwischen so viele
corona patienten auf den
intensivstationen wie nie zuvor
dass es so weit kam liege an der politik
meinen wissenschaftler was das bis jetzt
oft verabsäumt wurde es wirklich dass
man pro aktiv in das geschehen eingreift
wir sind immer hängt eigentlich hinken
wir ein paar schritte hinterher während
dem krankenhausärzte und corona
patienten kämpften tobte draußen das
leben tausende auf den beinen oft genug
auch ohne abstand ab heute jedoch die
geschäfte wieder zu ausgangs
beschränkungen ein haushalt darf sich
nur mit einer person treffen und an
belebten plätzen masken pflicht im
freien
der soll sich hier gestern gezeigt hat
verstehe ich sehr wohl dass die maske zu
tragen ist ich denke halt wenn wir alle
zusammenhalten dann geht das schneller
vorbei das bei frühsommerlichen
temperaturen auch die terrassen
geschlossen bleiben schmerzt die wiener
immerhin dürfen restaurants weiter
speisen zum mitnehmen anbieten
wir haben sicher über 90 prozent
verloren
also gute fünf jahre werden wir drunter
leiden er rechnet nicht damit sein
restaurant vor mitte mai wieder öffnen
zu dürfen
auch frankreich zieht die reißleine das
land geht zurück in den lockdown was
bisher nur in einigen regionen galt
betrifft ab samstag ganz frankreich
heißt für alle ausgangssperren ab 19 uhr
nicht lebensnotwendige geschäfte sind zu
und erstmals in diesem schuljahr auch
die schulen mindestens für drei wochen
das kündigte präsident makro an und
sprach von einem wettlauf gegen die zeit
die situation im land hat er sich
zuletzt deutlich verschärft die inzidenz
liegt bei 375 von corona zur
koalitionsfrage und zwar in baden
württemberg da wollten die grünen heute
entscheiden mit wem sie
koalitionsverhandlungen
gelungen aufnehmen doch es wurde noch
mal lange und heftig gestritten mit dem
ergebnis am samstag ein letztes
sondierungsgespräch mit der cdu als
basis für koalitionsverhandlungen
der populäre ministerpräsident
kretschmann hatte sich vehement für
grün-schwarz eingesetzt doch der
widerstand war groß möglich wäre nämlich
auch ein ampel bündnis mit spd und fdp
andreas linke in stuttgart warum tun
sich einige grüne in baden württemberg
so schwer damit ihrem erfolgreichen
ministerpräsidenten zu folgen
ja hier im haus der architekten in
stuttgart hätte man sich heute zum
ersten mal treffen wollen
wunschpartner der grünen des grünen
ministerpräsidenten wäre die cdu gewesen
aber der landesvorstand der das hätte
beschließen müssen
der hat er doch eine ganze reihe von
kritikpunkten noch gehabt zum einen
wollte man sich mehr schwung erwünschen
aus der eine ampelkoalition mit gelb und
rot und zum anderen ist auch kritik laut
geworden nämlich weil mit der cdu viele
dinge liegen geblieben sind in der
letzten legislaturperiode
wahlrechtsreformen steht da zum beispiel
auf dem zettel oder auch das bleiberecht
für flüchtlinge in arbeit
das ist dadurch auch der grund warum es
jetzt noch mal so eine sondierungsrunde
geben wird in dem man auch noch mal
punkte aus der sondierung fixieren will
um danach dann sozusagen mit hosenträger
und gehörte in koalitionsverhandlungen
mit der cdu einzustellen
lustiges bild dankeschön andreas linke
wer online hass botschaften verbreitet
und menschen bedroht muss jetzt mit
einer anklage rechnen denn am samstag
tritt ein neues gesetz in kraft zur
bekämpfung von rechtsextremismus und
hass kriminalität im internet das war
schon im sommer beschlossen worden aber
erst in dieser woche hat es der
bundespräsident unterzeichnet steinmeier
hatte eine neue regelungen zum zugriff
auf handy daten abgewartet
weiterer schlag für die
demokratiebewegung in hongkong ein
gericht hat sieben aktivisten für
schuldig befunden an einer
großdemonstration vor gut anderthalb
jahren teilgenommen beziehungsweise sie
selbst organisiert zu haben
peking geht uns
ich gegen die demokratiebewegung in
hongkong vor das bereitet vielen
bewohnern sorgen
rolf rolle sie haben angst ihre
gesichter zu zeigen denn sie wollen wie
viele andere familien hongkong verlassen
packen bereits ihre koffer
ihr sohn ist während der proteste zur
welt gekommen er soll in freiheit
aufwachsen sagen sie aber in hongkong
drohe ihm eine kommunistische erziehung
ich mache mir als vater große sorgen ich
glaube sie werden das schulsystem in
hongkong verändern und würden dann
meinen sohn irgendwann eine gehirnwäsche
unterziehen
wer es in hongkong waren china zu
kritisieren wird bestraft fast jede
woche ein prozess sieben prominente
vertreter der demokratiebewegung starten
heute vor gericht darunter der verleger
jimmy lee und der bekannte
oppositionspolitiker louen glocken im
august 2009 10 hatten sie eine
unerlaubte massendemonstration mit
organisiert das urteil schuldig es
drohen ihnen bis zu zehn jahre
nur eine kleine gruppe traut sich noch
dagegen zu protestieren
die damalige demonstration mit 1,7
millionen menschen war historisch allein
die teilnahme ehrt uns auch wenn wir
dafür jetzt ins gefängnis müssen
pekings machthaber machten kurzen
prozess mit der opposition in hongkong
jeden der damals demonstriert hat kann
es heute treffen in der stadt herrscht
viel angst
sie lieben hongkong aber sie glauben
nicht mehr an eine zukunft in ihrer
stadt
us präsident biden hat großes vor für
sein land er hat ein
investitionsprogramm angekündigt von
mehr als zwei billionen dollar das
entspricht etwa zehn prozent der
jährlichen wirtschaftsleistung der usa
straßen öffentlicher nahverkehr
elektromobilität all das soll auf
vordermann gebracht werden
finanziert durch eine höhere
unternehmenssteuern aus washington
benjamin daniel
sein schirm soll die rettung bringen
mehr als 2000 milliarden dollar gegen
marode brücken strassen ein veraltetes
gas strom und wassernetz oder für den
breitbandausbau beiden hatte sich im
wahlkampf immer wieder für die
verbesserung der infrastruktur
ausgesprochen jetzt also bringt er sein
gigantisches paket auf den weg
das ist eine investition für amerika die
nur einmal pro generation vorkommt
ungleich allem was wir seit dem bau der
autobahnen und dem wettrennen um den
weltraum vor jahrzehnten erlebt haben
es wäre das größte konjunkturprogramm in
der geschichte amerikas
laut dem us präsidenten soll es
millionen arbeitsplätze schaffen und den
usa helfen sich im wirtschafts wettlauf
mit china durchzusetzen
finanziert werden soll es unter anderem
durch eine anhebung der
unternehmenssteuer von 21 auf 28
also 100% anti trump kurs das ist ein
trojanisches pferd die rede ist von
infrastruktur aber eigentlich geht es
doch darum neue schulden zu machen und
die steuern für unternehmen zu erhöhen
nachdem pandemie rettungspaket stößt
beiden also gleich zu beginn seiner
amtszeit ein weiteres riesen vorhaben an
das muss er auch denn jetzt sind die
chancen wohl am größten ist durch den
kongress zu bekommen
die demokraten haben die mehrheit in
beiden kammern und das kann sich wie die
geschichte zeigt schnell ändern noch
eine interessante meldung für
bahnreisende sie müssen auf der
intercity strecke berlin-hannover bis
auf weiteres mit verspätungen rechnen
grund ist der zusammenstoß zweier loks
in wolfsburg gestern abend verletzt
wurde niemand aber die bergung könnte
laut bundespolizei tage dauern
die bahn leitet jetzt den fernverkehr
über braunschweig um und jetzt fußball
norbert denen nationalmannschaft hat
gestern nicht so wirklich freude gemacht
hat das hast du aber jetzt eher
wohlwollend formuliert bundestrainer
joachim löw selbst spricht von einer
bitteren niederlage seit fast 20 jahren
hatte die dfb-elf kein wm
qualifikationsspiel verloren
der siegreiche außenseiter mazedonien
der nord mazedonien der schreibt also
fußballgeschichte
für joachim löw ist es das letzte
wm-qualifikationsspiel als bundestrainer
und die erste niederlage
heute war das wirklich auch ein richtige
rückschlag keine auf dreierkette
umgestellte abwehr zeigt sich konfus und
desorientiert der 37-jährige pumps mit
dem 1 0 für nord mazedonien
die luis ag und die deutsche mannschaft
im glück dass es für dieses foul
elfmeter gibt ilkay gündogan mit dem
ausgleich in der 62 minute der kurz nach
der pause eingewechselte timo werner
vergibt diese grandiose gelegenheit zur
führung unfassbar
es stimmt vorne nicht gestimmt hinten
nicht das 2 1 für die gäste durch elmas
die alarmzeichen leuchtend rot
zweieinhalb monate vor beginn der
europameisterschaften die deutschen
handballer haben bei der auslosung für
die olympischen spiele in tokio eine
schwere gruppe erwischt die gegner unter
anderem europameister spanien und rekord
weltmeister frankreich viel härter hätte
es das team von bundestrainer alfred
gislason kaum treffen können
bei den olympischen spielen warten neben
spanien und frankreich
auch vize weltmeister norwegen brasilien
und argentinien als gruppengegner die
besten 14 ins viertelfinale ein in
dieser gruppe kein selbstläufer
und ich denke wir haben eine etwas
stärkere gruppe in der global das ticket
nach tokio hat deutschland sich beim
olympia-qualifikationsturnier
ungeschlagen gesichert positiv auch zwei
deutsche klubs spielen zurzeit noch im
achtelfinale der champions league
gestern gewann der thw kiel das hinspiel
in jacket mit fünf toren von
nationalspieler winzig überlegen mit 33
zu 28
so das war's auch schon fünf sport danke
das wetter über ostern wird vielfältig
kühn erst sonne dann schauer frost und
schnee sind auch dabei die details hat
gleich katja honnefer das heute journal
mit christian sievers um 10 hier geht es
direkt weiter mit dem zdf spezial und
wir sind morgen wieder hier um 7 ich
wünsche ihnen einen guten start ins
osterwochenende
[Musik]
meine damen und herren in
norddeutschland ist die markante
kaltfront bereits angekommen und sie
brachte einen richtigen temperatursturz
gestern gab es in kiel um 16 uhr noch
werte um 20 grad heute nur noch um 6 und
diese kaltfront brachte auch einige
regenschauer mit heute nacht gibt es
regenschauer in sachsen und am alpenrand
sonst ist es häufig klar und die
temperaturen sinken auf werte zwischen 8
grad am oberrhein und minus ein grad in
der lüneburger heide und morgen über tag
wird es dann auch in süddeutschland
kälter
da liegen die werte immerhin noch so bei
13 bis 18 grad meist aber ist es doch
april frisch mit höchstwerten zwischen 8
und 12 grad
das wird aber ein freundlicher
karfreitag sonne und wolken wechseln
sich ab bei einem lebhaften an der küste
auch starken wind aus nordwest anka
samstag gibt es eine kleine weiße
überraschung im erzgebirge oder auch im
oberfeld vom bayerischen wald da kann es
bis auf 600 meter herunter schneien
sonst aber wird häufig sonnig bei
temperaturen zwischen sechs und zwölf
grad
nach einer frostigen nacht erwartet uns
dann am ostersonntag viel sonnenschein
und an ostermontag ändert sich das
wetter von nordwesten wird es sehr viel
wechselhafter da kommen kräftige
regenfälle und schneefälle heran
schön auch noch